hello my name is Jorge Banuelos I'm a
second year PhD student in Yale's
Department of religious studies and The
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
likewise I have the pleasure of being
this year's graduate coordinator for
Yale center for the study of race
indigeneity and transnational migration
a matter of fact The rhythms the Rhythm
sitter is what connected us um where Dr
Leo Smith is a fall 2022 melon arts and
practitioner fellow with the center
um and I am very pleased to introduce
him I mean we're sitting here with a
living legend I can't overstate we're
here when they're truly prolific
avant-garde musician who I have the
honor and privilege of speaking with
Smith is a composer
multi-instrumentalist and an arranger
um
residencies you've had residencies at
the new school the Georgetown for
example um you were on the faculty for
Cal for Cal Arts correct yes yeah and
you were there for about 20 or so years
22. honorary doctorate and then also uh
faculty at Meredith as well yes um and
then also started your own record label
I think by Michael over what about 50
albums uh I got over 100.
so my count was off
um and then likewise finalists for the
2013 Pulitzer Prize in music also 2016
recipient of the Doris Duke award wow
Matt so let me just I guess I'll just
start by way of antidote so I first had
the privilege of meeting with Dada um
earlier in the fall you gave a lecture
at Timothy Dwight College on campus um
speaking beforehand on the lecture I was
supposed to run the clicker I said man
don't worry about it we'll just
improvise this Jazz he recoil
would you mind telling us in a sense why
the words Jazz and improvisation are not
words that are in your Lexicon well
essentially they was not intended for
music
and those terms was he actually uh
forced upon
African-American artistic Community as a
as a term that defined what they did
um one of the tradition that humans
practice all over the world and it's
rare
to be denied it is a naming process
humans named their location their
siblings
their notion of what they do in life all
kinds of naming processes go on so when
when
the people looked at the music coming
out of early New Orleans which is
actually the southern cradle of this
music
they tagged it as uh Jazz and that it
had improvisation in it and all that
kind of stuff well improvisation in the
Lexicon uh about 300 and something BC
you see and uh uh it was dealing with
theater had nothing to do with music
okay and the word Jazz come from a
baseball term where they tried to uh
explain the kind of energy used in
participation of that that ball gang
yeah yeah and so why would you call a
music jazz or why would you employ the
word improvisation when they have no
meaning whatsoever to that music
secondly if you look at the definition
improvisation means virtually nothing is
a collection of words that you can't
even get a clear meaning out of you see
to do something off handily that don't
mean nothing
uh so I reject anything that's forced
upon me or anything that's Force upon uh
the people that I'm associated with and
that's that's the clearest way I can
Define it yeah well let me ask you a
follow-up on that yeah um so I gave an
introduction but it's always more
special When someone tells us in their
own words who they are so would you mind
introducing yourself and telling me who
you are and how you narrate yourself
well I'm a human being
my existence on the planet has something
to do with my uh
uh
character of making art and make it not
in the present
um I'm a family person I love family
because that's the basic unit of
humanity
and um
I like thinking and deep reflecting
about stuff
prizes and ceremonies and things like
that are very important but they have
very little
uh practically use other than the fact
that somebody gives you some more or
they some some
but the whole point is is that I think
of myself as a creative person
who is constantly looking and striving
to discover
not just who I am but to destruct
discover the largest a larger picture of
what this Human Experience can be you
say
um so that's my my that's how I would
describe myself something along the
lines of the Blues and the abstract
truth
it could be a way of thinking about it
but seeing the notion of the Blues I
actually destroys what one would be
because
um uh
Blues
is a cultural
of
notion about a society
it's a psychological
way of presenting
information into the society larger part
of the society
um
when we think about Blues we always
think about this notion of 12 bars or
somebody singing about something sad
well that ain't none of that's true
you see uh John Lee Hooker for example
he doesn't observe no 12 hour frame for
the blues he plays as low as he would on
any one of those supposedly courts that
associated with with the blues and he
changed whenever he wants to
but even that's superficial because that
has no real true meaning that is that he
doesn't observe this
formalized form that people have gone
accustomed to that they identify with
Blues
so what I'm trying to tell you is that
Blues has several categories
like for example
um uh uh Robert Johnson
Robert Johnson gives a exposition
on a piece that's called um I forget the
title of the piece but the lyrics go
like this
when you when I die you can bury my old
body body beside the highway
so when the Greyhound bus come along
I can get up and take a ride hmm
now that seemed like a nice kind of a
collection of words
but that that's deep meaning in that
it says the same thing that any
philosopher from Nietzsche to uh
Pythagoras to whoever
it says the same thing about the the
life
that one survived survives death because
if it's old body is buried beside the
highway can get them to take a ride on
the Greyhound bus which is a physical uh
characteristics of traveling it means
that that life or that Consciousness or
that person survive down
but he says it within the limits of two
and a half minutes
not a book that has 500 pages or a
thousand pages in it that that goes
Ramblers on and on and on and on and on
it's it's one of the most succinct
definitions about this idea of
Consciousness surpassing death
so that's one quality John Lee Hooker
has a blues just called uh Tupelo flood
that's that's what we just got to talk
about that's that's a philosophical
Blues
and the other one the Tupelo flood he
talks about is the actual event that
happened so it's a hysterical Blues
and you can go on and identify and
identify all the way down the line all
these characteristics that are
associated with the blues where in fact
the person that's truly receiving this
information
would gleam those kinds of qualities
that I'm talking about about it and not
the fact that it was that it has uh 12
balls or 32 balls or 19 balls of one and
a half balls long or that it has these
old cause of sadness or something some
you say all that stuff is dust
but the real humans supposed to look
through dust and see because it does
cells after a while gravity takes care
of that mm-hmm
I mean there are a couple ideas a lot of
ideas on what you just said um I I think
there's one of them I do want to hop on
to yes about the existential quality of
it that in a sense because to me I'm a
musician as well
um part of to me with the appeal of
being someone who makes music but then
also deeply appreciates the art form is
the kind of immediate arrest you can get
out of it that and what you're saying
about that blue you know that Blues line
that you mentioned that there's kind of
like an immediate haptic quality to it
like it reaches out and kind of grabs
you or touches you um is that related to
inspiration like like how yeah that's
that's the form of being uh say how do
you say the uh informed it's more like
an informed notion where where you
actually are able to capture the
information that's hidden in the line in
the poetic line you say
um and then secondly that that kind of
uh activity is called you know you
discover you're digging underneath the
lyrics to find the truth or what's being
spoken about you see so so yeah you
could say that it does inspire you a one
to look deeper each time for something
but the the notion of inspiration that
we that we normally talk about and
associate with art has to do with this
idea that new information is received
and it's received if you create a
musician
it's received
in the present moment while the activity
of making that art piece is happening so
The Unsung is playing and somebody said
nothing someone gets inspired and that
inspiration is new information that's
put into the pool and that delivers
something different
then something that's formalized and and
just practice and and delivered as what
it is and I don't mean to say that a
piece that's all written cannot be uh
cannot carry inspiration it can okay uh
many artists do goes and included have
pieces that have that are completely
written out okay and they are also uh
have come from inspiration
and have this triggering quality when
it's performed to inspire or be a source
of inspiration for the performer same
thing could be said about
um uh a composer like let's say let's
use an old guy like uh Bach or Beethoven
their music is all written now
okay
but that music came from inspiration
and it also the performance performance
can reach a level of creativity where it
also
to perform it in that certain way they
have to also receive inspiration how to
do it
receive inspiration so like not
necessarily generate or come up with
your own but it seems like the
inspiration is coming from somewhere
else yes do you have a like can you
could you put words in a sense to what
inspiration is and where it might come
from or and where does your inspiration
come from well all inspiration come from
the same place and it's unknown it's
called The Unknown or the Unseen
and uh uh
the idea of inspiration means to be
inspired or to be input something is
input
and to describe it it's like a stream
that flows through you only for a few
few moments you can't even calculate it
in terms of second there's a few moments
it flows through you and once it passes
through you it leaves this imprint there
and what's imprinted there is just for
that moment
and if it's used in a performance of any
kind whether it be dancing painting
writing thinking or whatever
it flows right through and that's it
comes out for that moment you see but
that moment is like a spark in a world
that's completely dark
that spark lasts forever
because what was created from it is
going to be part of the human Dimension
Forever both in terms of actuality as a
work of art
or as a memory
those things are going to constantly be
reincarnated or reinvented through the
population of those that are experience
it so so so the seed is this big from
the moment of actual expression it gets
larger and larger and larger and if
somebody writes about it that's another
source where it's actually being
spreaded out you see so so it actually
has something that it gives
both in a physical sense and also a
mental sense where it actually
continuously to live and
um
I may remind you that nothing that's in
creation
did not is is here and did not just not
come into creation is always here
and that which is here
can never leave
I'm paraphrasing invasive the law of
thermodynamics
you say it can never leave
um uh spiritual taxes State the same
thing in a different way
but it never leaves
you say yeah so in a sense it kind of
sounds like there's a absolute or an
eternal and then a contraction of that
into the world that we live in and then
you know if we Orient ourselves if we
practice for it we might be lucky enough
to become a medium for it to continue
and move forward yeah yeah the practice
of it is is is is a quite simple thing
that is one have to be be desired in in
a need and in search of it and then when
it does happen uh one needs to be able
to capable of using it
um everybody's inspiring
most people don't know what inspiration
means they don't know what it feels like
inside of themselves mostly people who
perform artistic works uh recognize it
more than ordinary people
and um uh that's because there's
constantly searching and striving to
discover something you say ordinary
people have these same kinds of
inspiration
uh it comes into them the same way but
they they don't pay attention to it
often
uh they call it like daydreaming of
fantasy or or some vague idea or
something and and they don't act on it
they just keep moving past it but it
comes through everybody because if a
person is being actually inspired and
you're standing close to them some of
that wave hits you as well okay yeah
so in relation to because you're
multi-instrumentalism I assume that you
still practice down to these days yeah
yeah I see a practice I won't say how
much but I see a practice Yeah because
I'm also asking too because for myself
I'm a drummer um I've noticed that
practicing nowadays has moved a lot
towards technique and also making sure
that when inspiration comes I'm actually
kind of ready for the idea to manifest
in that moment um in a sense how do you
practice like like how would you report
how do you how do you teach practicing
and then how do you personally approach
it yeah actually practice important a
bit later but let me say this uh let me
talk about technique
uh we've been taught that technique is
something that's told to you it's not
it's not quite true technique is the way
that you do something
every time you go out of your house and
unlock the door to unlock the door or
come in and lock the door that's a
that's a practical way that you get into
your doorway it's a technique that's
that's that's how you do it same thing
with the way in which you uh uh uh do
your research
let me say or how you take a walk
all these things are ways and means
towards
something
and when we talk about about artistic
technique it's always implies that it
had been been established and endorsed
by some kind of a teacher or somebody
with somebody something and what I'm
trying to say is that technique is
actually the way that you do something
how you do it and the skill was with you
or able to to do it with they say so so
how do you gain that technique you gain
that technique by aligning yourself to
be deeply aware of what you're doing and
to take note of it mentally or otherwise
of how
one
does it or how it's done you see and
that began to be part of your uh
kit
which you work through and work with
Okay Braxton
um
a lot of people practice from
you know how they teach and talk to them
to practice
a lot of people practice
from how you think about practice should
be
um
I say find out how you learn how to
practice by practicing and the way to do
that is is not to fix anything about
what it is how your practice for
drummers uh there's a different set of
things that you practice for when this
semester a different set of things same
thing for Strings and so on okay
um
for Drummond
everybody wants to be impressive
so they practice stuff that would make
them appear to be impressive that
everybody can say wow that's that's that
that's that's that no
um
uh
there are drummers out there
uh that play with what appears to be no
train technique whatsoever
and of course they make the largest
impact in the world
they are dramas who were extremely
trained
but are able to overpass their training
and and actually do something that's
that's absolutely phenomenal that's a
Tony Williams for example uh the early
drum I was thinking about was uh
um we call them Big Chief I'm trying to
think of his his uh his name he played
with Abbott Island and those people
um
Sonny Murray
Sonny Murray plays the drums like
like nobody you've ever heard before
okay
and his impact
is is tremendous it's tremendous okay I
mean like like
the difference between him
he's a new set of baby dogs as baby died
was in the 20s to everybody else
so that's that's the distinction
so so so what I'm telling you this is
that if one is in a school
you gotta find a way
to discover that real part of what
you're doing and why you're there and if
you're not in the school
you still gotta find the real part of
what you're doing and why you're there
and just why are you in creation
and once you discover even a part of
that you've come close to where you're
at that means you come closer realizing
your your own State
you say and what is that on state that's
a that's a true State I mean it's called
Uh uh I'll get him back to your original
Self you know yeah reminds me of this
quote by Ralph Ellison the author of
Invisible Man one of my favorite quotes
where he says good fiction um is made up
of reality the reality is hard to come
by yeah
it's true yeah yeah yeah
yeah because it also sounds like two in
the in the style of practice or
technique practice you know just
performing getting getting the ideas out
that also it's it's training
Consciousness in a sense too that yes
you become aware of technique you become
aware of some things that you do that
kind of seem as if they're just floating
in the background so like for example
when you drummers they tell you practice
with a metronome you're not getting it
slow the metronome down moving slower
gives you more of an opportunity to kind
of hear the the fine grains of where
certain beats are laid out but it's also
training the mind in a sense to be able
to hear to perceive to have better more
accurate perception and it sounds also
in a sense that to be able to perceive
what is really real yeah that's one way
the other way is to just feel it
because because because of stroke once
you make a stroke
it's already has set up something and
what is what what comes after that
something comes after that and the
feeling tells you
it nourishes you to stroke again in a
certain way and if it tells you to
stroke more than one time and all these
things are faster than they're almost
faster than than reasoning or logic
so you so you awaken from your intuitive
self that's stroking and that becomes
the
um
that's a far more powerful key than the
metronome because just you got to
remember baby died they didn't have no
metronomes you know right again you say
what they understood was is that if you
initiate something
that's the beginning and at that
beginning opens up all kinds of other
possibilities and that other possibility
if he's drumming or she's drumming it's
the notion of how it feels that the next
stroke comes in and like I say this
stuff is fast as enlightening you don't
have to sit there and tabulate it and
add it up it's already it doesn't go on
50 000 Strokes away from that adding up
metabolation of it you know so so yeah
metronome can can be a buy Source you
know but also
um what overrides the metronome as
you're feeling yeah because then going
back to the idea you were talking about
with some drummers or musicians in
General
um who don't necessarily adhere to a
school or it's you know style or who are
not trying to have that kind of
discipline at least to be disciplined by
something or someone Beyond themselves
but it's a matter of GrooVe pocket does
it feel good is it
well don't call the group just call it
feeling because group implies some
historical reference to to a beat and
it's not about a being because the beat
is by the column and it's not about
account that's what I'm saying it's
about feeling it's more about feeling I
mean uh a guy like a Max Roach uh uh
they cannot throw out those unusual
accents that's that's a 34th
on the end of a set of figures they
can't throw it out if they're trying to
count it can only be done by feeling you
see and then when people try to tabulate
they would need a machine to tabulate it
you say the reason why is because they
they count they count
which is which is always about metrics
that's not it you see there are other
kinds of rhythms out there uh my music
explosives as well but they're they're
called proportional they're not based
off of uh a metrical cycle America's
cycle has either these are 12 strokes
and divided
or four strokes in the divided or two
strokes in a divided it's all metrics
and there's a limit to it if you have if
you look at the Indian system where they
have have this horizontal strain of of
numbers thrown out you add them all up
and if they come out to even number then
you divide it up evenly and you can say
that it's it's twenty five thousand four
fours okay or if it's uneven you can say
it's it's five thousand four fours two
thousand three fours one thousand one
fours you say but still all measuring
proportion deals with long and short
relationship and you get rid of the
fixity too yeah you get rid of the fixed
quality of it is that it's either long
or it's either short and it alternates
between those
long long long short or short long short
short short long short long short long
that's not going to come up you can't
even count that up in terms of
these markers I'm talking about
metrically because the impetus
just like the idea of feeling it's been
pulled away from the metrics and there
are only two kinds of Rhythm those are
metrical rhythms and those which are
based off of proportion yeah man I don't
know I might have to disagree with you I
like I like the fixed beats but maybe
that's just me
liking is overrated
they liking liking this base off I need
somebody license brings off a lot of
expectation and and stuff like that but
you know uh you can knock stuff but uh
when they when the lights go out dislike
it
hey so this is a good segue to move into
something that I forgot to mention
earlier which is you have your own
language for doing musical notation
would you speak a little bit about that
yeah it's called Uncle transformation on
across Mason Uncle transformation so
like ankh rossiation yes and Unk of
course is the Egyptian uh cross which
which which means uh uh vital life force
basically because when you look at the
the temple drawings they pointed towards
the head they pointed towards the mouth
and nose because that's the breath they
pointed me across the neck and the
chairs and sometimes they pour it over
top of the head okay uh so Unk means
vital life force uh and it's a cross
that's like that
okay
um
Ross come from the the Amharic which is
the ancient Egyptian language I mean uh
Ethiopian language
um it made him come from geese but we
had it rendered in in Amharic and Ross
means head which which which infers the
father
because we're talking about a family
unit
and Mars is the mother son
so if you look at Uncle rosmation it
means the vital life force a mother and
father
which is the which is the total
organic in which
reproduction and creativity is taking
place through
so it's not named after some musical
thing it's named after the actual source
of regeneration that takes place between
the idea of mother and father you see so
so when you look at that it's a symbolic
language
uh and by symbolic meaning that that it
has
figures
or or symbols it has color
everything that's connected with it has
to be referenced or put in place by the
person that's making the observation of
the score
and uh
uh uh it's a score that
that that's also based off the notion of
regeneration
the velocity units which deals with with
with with uh stuff that's that has a lot
of activity in it
as for different density levels that is
levels of for thickness and Etc
uh that's on the fast side on the slow
side it has four levels of of lessening
of density it begins to from from one to
four to this will ever be begin to
decrease
and so there's again this this this idea
of the right and left long and short
and then the Rhythm units there are six
sets of those actually seven but I only
use six nowadays
um they also have this notion of
Longshore Longshore Longshore based off
of six sets Okay
um
uh the point I'm trying to make this is
that the language
is uh was was discovered in 1967 on a
Saturday morning
and uh
it's still growing uh in uh what is it
okay because as I was saying that when
you really get deep into language and
particularly symbolic language every
object that we see around us
inside or outside of building all of
that is language all of that all of it
and all of it came from inspiration you
see that Camel wasn't constructed by
some person they wanted to construct
something because they had an idea no
they were inspired to look for how to do
that hmm so two more questions then so
the first one is um you lived a number
of places but New Haven is home is there
something about New Haven that charms
you like like is there something special
about New Haven that really attracts you
to it
well it is but um it'll take me a long
time to explain all right just give a
little bit I'm gonna give you a little
bit but I'm saying that that there are
other things that attract me but the
most important one is my family they
live here in the New Haven area which as
we know is a fairly large area it's got
Hamilton and North Haven and a thousand
other Havens you know
um essentially it's a small town I like
small towns
that's about the cold weather ah good
good good and then lastly so I mean I've
obviously very prolific what's next
everything
anything more specific than everything
well
um
I'm about to hopefully by the middle of
this by summertime conclude a work that
has uh 26 compositions in it that has
I've been working on for the last 50
years
uh it's 10 hours and a half of actual
music time needs to be played over four
days that's one of the four or five
different projects I'm working on right
now so
that's what I mean by everything
again one more time it's truly been a
pleasure thank you so much yes thank you
[Music]